I think he wants you
Jake's very special
He's always liked doing things his own way
Where are you guys applying?
Oh boy
Even if we could afford it,
is a private school even what I want for Jake?
I know we've always said
we're not those parents, but...
Well, we can't afford to be.
No, but maybe...
The numbers are ridiculous,
but what you have to remember...
Everybody wants diversity
Why not talk a little about his gender expansive play?
You want him to be somewhere he can thrive, right?
You really don't think it's weird?
I mean, he does like to play dress-up.
That's not news
Yeah, he likes fairy tales, but maybe
that's not the most critical thing worth mentioning.
He asked why boys can't wear skirts
I don't want to send him off to kindergarten labeled.
He's only four
What if he starts thinking
there's something wrong with him?
Where is my favorite grandson?
I haven't heard from you
in over a week
Gotta push, push, push!
Gotta let go, right?
In a few weeks, we'll visit some new schools,
and you should just be yourself
That's all that matters, okay?
There's no big deal at all.
Yeah
I'd like to show you something
There were one or two incidents in class
I hate you!
Kindergarten, it's so hard for a child, you know, who...
Who what?
You two have some choices to make here
Maybe we should bring him to see someone
Maybe the problem is
that we started pushing him into this role
You're the one buying him every princess DVD
you can get your hands on...
and then freaking out when people start to notice
Is it any wonder he's confused?
You try so hard to protect them, but...
It's never gonna be easy to really see people
Especially the ones we love
One, two, three, whee!